this whole quit here on the sidewalk it
gives you results but it's it's not
perfect like you go do a little extra
way is one of the reasons why we're
going to look at today's concept okay so
draw yourself up a new brand of triangle
but if you draw it like this that'll
help you keep up with what we're all
doing when we did this last time we said
excuse me this is not right angled this
is not right angle but we can put some
right angle triangles in there and then
we can try and get some relationships in
there we used sign admits all of the
science that we have here right
but because sign looks like this and if
you have some value by where I'm at 0.57
okay so if this is 1 then 0.57 then I
get my two solutions and that's why
there's this problem okay but that only
comes about because of what sign looks
like that's the shape of science so what
if I tried something else what if I
tried well cosine is the next obvious
choice right I've got sine cosine tale
so in this tranquil we're going to try
and go through a similar process what
we're going to use cosine instead right
it's not right angled so in order to use
the trigonometry that I know at the
moment I'm gonna put some right angles
in there does anyone remember if I put
this line down it's perpendicular what's
that line called that's of an egg we
tend to talk about planes having this
kind of thing it's the arm it's the
altitude
it's an LT also in this case it's the
particular holiday so I've got this
labeled in because it is like the
perpendicular height I'm gonna call this
H and our conventions for science and
points of how they match up is that for
instance if this is capital B what would
we usually call this length over here
we're clods Bobby lowercase me
this is gonna be lowercase C I mean you
could opposite that looks like that
makes this lowercase a down the bottom
now I'm going to write this length just
a bit further off okay because what I
want to put close to me is the side legs
of these two smaller triangle
so just for convenience I'll call this
Little Neck feet from here that points
we want paper boy
I'm gonna call BP and call that link X
right because I don't know what this
right if that little like this X what's
the left I thought what is page see how
long is that it's gonna be now I could I
could I could introduce another letter
right but I can phrase it in terms of
letters I already know the printable I
already do yes this length is the
holding a takeaway this X that I just
introduced a similar thing so so I could
say um BC or I could just use my
lowercase a and that'll be on so you
happy with that
a takeaway house now we're going to use
cosine okay we're gonna use cosine
instead of sine but before I reach them
that I noticed that because I've got
these why they do triangles I can use
Pythagoras in this pair of triangles as
well right because H is kind of like the
connecting piece between the two drivers
I'm going to say in this left-hand
triangle in triangle a big pig okay
through Pythagoras I can make a
statement about H square okay like this
squared that's grabbed the spring and at
the same time in this right head
triangle I can say in triangle what's a
corner a CP instead of maybe big I could
say another thing about H squared now
just to pause right mathematicians do
this all the time
they look at the one object and they try
and approach it from different angles
literally right try get a different
perspective on the same thing and that
tends to get inside it's a mathematical
thing to do so over here right H squared
it's not the hypotenuse is it okay so I
can't say H squared equals something
squared plus something squared because
it's the shortest side what should I say
instead
I'm going to do takeaway right so I've
got C squared there's the hypotenuse
over here opposite the my table takeaway
expert are you content with that square
equals MC squared and that's my
co-founders it's an implication of
planet over here I'll do exactly the
same thing except this is my hypotenuse
right to base with what am I taking away
yeah I've got a minus X and I've got a
square that whole thing right a whole
side a minus X that has to be squared
and it's the whole space sit there with
me now that I know what H squared is and
I've seen it from two different angles
because it's equal missed but it's also
even this it's pretty reasonable to
speak that this and this are really
actually equal to each other so I can
kind of cut the middle bit has it worked
right so I can now say therefore which
side am I going to pretty much say I'm
going to put I'm gonna put C squared
minus x squared equals B squared minus a
minus X are you okay with that you can
see they're they're both versions of h
squared you can tell me that so if it's
in with that anything with that this
should be equal to each other so far so
good
now this is true this is true but I want
to simplify this a little bit and I know
in advance before I do anything I should
be able to simplify somehow I go can you
see there's an x squared there right or
a minus x squared on the right-hand side
there's something I can expand once I do
it because there's an X and it's being
squared right
I'm going to expect that there will be a
minus x squared on the right hand side
as well if you've got the same thing on
the left as you have on the right you
can get rid of both of them okay so
that's kind of what I'm anticipating
let's give this a go there's not much to
do on the left hand side
let's expand out this right-hand side a
bit b-squared take away what is a minus
X wants you to square what am I gonna
get I'm gonna get a squared by this two
- what's this one - ax very good and
then it's okay so I'm doing is there and
then you take that X when you square it
right but because - accident gets
squared the negative disappears so it's
plus x squared it's more but you see
what I've done
okay so experiment and I still have my C
squared minus x squared hanging over
there Melissa
now on the right hand side I'm gonna
take away in front of this whole set of
brackets watch for this by the way I
could have done this directly in one
step but because doing double negatives
is an error that people make all the
time even people been doing maths for a
long time it's worth doing that extra
step to make sure we don't accidentally
muck something up so I'm going to do
these one at a time a B squared minus a
squared double negative there so plus
2ax are you happy with that
yep what am I gonna have over here minus
x squared
ah that was the thing I was looking for
right because I have a minus x squared
here and I also have a minus x squared
there that's really good Maxo forgot the
same thing on both sides one two I can
get rid of it from both sides
okay so this is looking good now I just
have C squared over there then I've got
B squared minus a squared costs
hmm okay you happy so far so far things
are looking good okay now what can I do
with this because I have C PMA right
that's really good they're the three
sides of my original triangle you
remember that okay but I've got this
pesky ex hanging around I don't really
want that to there okay I want that to
be replaced by something in terms of the
a and B and C that I started with okay
so here's how I'm going to do where
where is X in this diagram it's in this
left-hand triangle this guy that guy so
here's where I'm gonna pull cosine you
right if I say hmmm how can I get rid of
the X let's think about things from this
point of view this little angle over
here right I could have chosen a
different angle if I wanted to sign but
this angle is adjacent to X do you see
that it's adjacent and that's why I go
to cosine because you remember that
cosine is one which relates the adjacent
side to this hypotenuse which is the
absolutely the side of the bigger
triangle okay so therefore I'm gonna
pause this for a second I'm going to say
in triangle now have a look it's on this
guy to get a BP I can say cos cos of
this angle over here right cause all
is equal to what's it equal to x over c
adjacent are you happy about so never
here I just need to tweak it a little
bit to say well what's X equal to once
I've got x equals to something I can
replace whatever that's equal to its
going to be C because b do you see that
I just read that C over the other side
don't get freaked out that there are two
seasonal road it's okay once a length
one spot of course okay so now this is
great I can use this I'm going to pop it
up into here so I can say C squared
equals let's have a look at this 2a
times this guy this is what I'm
replacing X with replacing it see cause
hmm I'm gonna do one more step to make
this nice and clean okay I can see see a
B and C right I could have rearranged
them I could rotate it in any way that I
liked right so I could have for example
instead of drawing this altitude I could
draw it that way or I couldn't draw it
that way okay so I'm going to rearrange
the letters ever so slightly right from
this line I will use it I want to say
okay
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
swap B and C around everywhere I see a
beep I'm going to swap it for a see
right so that gives me a whoops okay so
all I've done it's exactly the same
statement right I'm just looking at it
from a different angle okay literally
from a different angle so I'll swap my
B's and my seats and they're all fine
now see how I've got an a squared and B
squared and a C squared right
we use a squared + B squared C squared
in Pythagoras all the time in fact
Pythagoras almost Springs out of the
trap usually we have C square as the
subject of Pythagoras C squared is equal
to something right I'm going to make it
the subject now I'm gonna say C squared
is equal to and so I'm going to get all
this other stuff on the other side of
the equation you see that I want it by
itself so therefore I'm going to add a
sweat I've already got a B squared hang
it over there this is a plus so it's
going to become a minus on the other
side and now I'm going to stop now I
want you to look at this and I've put a
big box around because it's cold and
this is my heading it's called the
cosine rule okay just like we had the
same rule
this is using cause instead this thing
is ingenious this thing is beautiful
right what it shows you is look at this
this part is Pythagoras you know
Pythagoras we've been using Pythagoras
for years right Pythagoras theorem works
in all trend was not just the right
angle ones provided you add this little
extra bit over here we can explore on
Tuesday why this extra bit gets added
and how it kind of modify the trailer
okay but we can use this anytime we like
that we fought to find each side okay so
you could be blocks around it
label at the cur sidewalk let me give
you an example with concrete numbers